Nick Jonas is literally my daddy yes
he's so hot and he sings so good [ __ ] I
can tell you this I'm definitely not
your daddy
I'm 100 percent sure of that 100 percent
sure
[Music]
hey it's Nick Jonas and today i'll be
reading thirst tweets let's get to it
this is the LOL bucket the first tweets
of thirst is dear Nick Jonas you
literally make me want to set myself on
fire from your immense sexiness so if
you could dial it down a bit okay thanks
well listen here can't dial it down
that's bananas
I want Nick Jonas to start starts are
the absolute star stars are out of my
star star star star star star sorry
what's a star
I might get Nick Jones's face tattooed
on my left ass cheek so I can say I sit
on Nick Jones's face all the time it's
pretty clever actually
which facial expression would you like
to have tattooed on this one please hold
or this one I think the second cuz then
maybe the other thumb will come up
depending on [ __ ] back there gab
says Nick Jonas could choke me on any
holy day into choking huh makes two of
us Nick Jonas eat bacon off my naked
body I don't know it might not be the
cleanest surface to eat bacon off of
usually I go for a plate or perhaps a
cheeseburger maybe after a shower or
something you could talk about it works
up and out I have this recurring fantasy
now where Nick Jonas puts me between his
thighs and crushes my potty I do have
very strong thighs probably not strong
enough to crush your entire body though
but we can give it a try if you really
want to next Jonas can bite my nipple
and snatch it out of my body and I'd say
thanks daddy
that's an odd bite my nipple and snatch
it out of my body that makes no sense
whatsoever Nick Jonas is so hot I can
feel it radiating my kneecaps my dad
used to say that about the weather you'd
say oh I think the storms coming and
feeling my kneecaps but not about you
know Farrah Fawcett's hair or something
he's different lingo regarding that
Nick Jonas could literally rip me to
shreds interesting I think I know what
you're talking about I'm pretty sure I
get the innuendo there rip you to shreds
interesting well that's all the thirst
tweets I have a few more of my direct
messages that I could show you at a
different time but that's for the
r-rated version for now this has been
thirst toys with me Nick Jonas peace
[Music]